yeah and thank you all for coming I'm
very excited and feel privileged to be
here so today I'll give you I'll be
giving my thesis defense talk title
designing Institute interaction with
ubiquitous robots and so the field of
Robotics have been growing tremendously
in the past few decades
instead of being restricted to factories
where only expert users were allowed to
interact with robots and even then
behind glass walls
now robots are increasingly becoming
parts of our daily lives interacting
with us in many different ways we see an
increase in number of robots as well as
type of robots ranging from humanoid
robots in STEM education and shopping
malls to non humanoid robots and in the
form of vacuum robots and autonomous
vehicles and so we have seen similar
trends in computing where computers were
initially isolated and used only by
experts and as technology matured we
start to see that see the emergence of
personal personal computers and now we
see that computers are everywhere and
everyone interacts with many computing
devices and so we see this overall
exponential growth and number of
computing devices and dkn size and so
while robotic isn't-isn't
in this exact same station now we
believe that it'll follow a similar
trend we'll see an exponential growth in
number of robots and decrease in size of
the robots and as size of robots
decrease their capacity to do meaningful
work also decreases and so one of the
ways to overcome this is to use a large
number of robots that can collectively
achieve meaningful tasks and so one
technology that enables this is swarm
robotics researchers in this field have
looked at how to leverage large number
of robots to accomplish meaningful tests
that otherwise would have been
impossible alone and so robots have been
used in applications like search and
rescue where efficient and fast
coverages of large areas are needed they
can also work together to manipulate
heavy objects they can collectively they
can also collectively train our navigate
through uneven complex terrains and so
these multi robot systems have been too
in specific locations like warehouses to
efficiency efficiently sort packages and
so as we approach this era of ubiquitous
robots the interaction between the user
and robots become more and more
important and so in this work I propose
this concept of ubiquitous robotic
interfaces or your eyes where we'll be
seeing swarms of small robots they'll be
physically moving around
and since our environment they also
collectively manipulate objects around
us for us and they will interact with us
when it's necessary and so researchers
have studied mostly the functional
components of your eyes such as sensing
and manipulation but a key question that
still remains is how do we enact with
them and so to study this I first broken
broke it down into two components
especially I was interested in learning
how should the robots display
information to the users such that it's
comprehensible and how can you allow
users to command large number of robots
so in terms of display or output from
the robots earlier works in HRI or human
robot interaction have explored
designing output with humanoid robots so
in addition to verbal communications
features researchers have looked at
leveraging anthropomorphic features like
the facial expression gaze gesture as
well as posture so while these features
are useful for social interaction many
robots do not have these features and
would require additional hardware which
can be costly
it can also mislead users into
overestimating robots social skills and
it's high resemblance to human can limit
how easily these robots blend in to our
environment so to address these issues
people have looked at one feature that
is common across most if not all robots
their mobility and so prior works from
psychology such as hydro and Simoes
animation have shown the immense
expressive power that motion has just by
having simple geometries move in
particular way we
able to convey comprehensible
information such as intent or effect of
these simple geometries and so recent
works in HR I have leveraged exactly
this to to create more expressive non
humanoid robot they use different motion
features like trajectory or speed to
successfully convey abstract information
like intent or effect in terms of
command or input to the users research
researchers have looked at different
ways and those include verbal voice
control nonverbal through gesture or
controllers as well as programming which
is primarily used by experts and so most
of the prior work deals with one-on-one
human robot interaction and when we
scale this interaction to multi robot
systems there are several challenges
that arise both in terms of input and
output first multi robot systems have
significant higher degrees of freedom
than a single robot and so to display
meaningful information a naive approach
would involve applying findings from a
single robot to each of the robots
however that approach may not yield the
same results as prior work has shown
that people's perception changes based
on the number of robots so it's
necessary to find a more effective
approach that truly leverages and take
advantages take advantage of the high
degree of freedom of a multi robot
system in terms of input it's also
difficult to know what is the best way
to enable users to effectively control
command such a large number of robots
another challenge is that as these
robots become ubiquitous the robots need
to have this ability to interact with
anyone at anytime and so as we see
robots will become increasingly
versatile completing many tasks but
there still be around people and so they
need this ability to communicate and
interact with people even during the
task and in terms of input again the
robots will be around people and so will
be in public and personal spaces so they
need to be usable even by people who
don't have prior experience interacting
with a robot and lastly the robots need
to adapt to how people in our
research have shown that human
inherently interact with the world
through different sensory channels we
communicate verbally and non-verbally
through gesture and touch so in order to
provide this seamless interaction robots
will also need to leverage Oh display
information through these channels as
well as understand multimodal input from
the users and so the goal of this thesis
is to design this multimodal and
ubiquitous in action patterns with multi
robot systems to achieve this my
approach has been to first develop and
use interactive multi robot platforms
prior work since former buttocks and
multi robot systems have mostly focused
on developing hardware that is specially
designed to complete a task and so it
doesn't have the features necessary for
real-time interactions such as fast
robots and ability to detect users input
to address this my colleagues and I
built new interactive platforms and then
design multimodal interaction patterns
that leverages these different sensory
channels as well as the high degree of
freedom of a multi robot system and
lastly I included people in the process
so I either studied how human perceive
different types different stimuli that I
design or a code design with the
participants by having them generate the
propia stim life for different
interactions and so in this thesis I
look at both how to display information
with multi robot systems primarily using
motion as its one of the common feature
across most if not all robots and how I
investigated how to enable users to
command large number of robots in terms
of display I looked at how to leverage
motion to visually convey information
especially when the robots are out of
reach as well as through touch when the
robots are dear by users for the visual
display I looked at how to embed
expressiveness as well as intent into
the swarm robot motion and for touch I
looked at how people perceive different
touch stimuli from the robots as well as
how people use robots to convey
different touch messages and lastly I
investigated
how to enable users to command large
number of robots and because prior works
have prior work has mostly focused on
developing a functional mean that is not
based on how users prefer to control a
large number of robots so to study these
problems I first build a multi robot
platform named Zoe together with our
previous postdoc Mutulu gah so it is an
open source platform that consists of
multiple mobile robots controlled by a
central computer the size and form
factor allows them to more easily blend
into our environment and allow users to
manipulate multiple robots
simultaneously and each of the robots
consists of the following parts and that
allows them to localize detect touch
move and communicate with a central
computer it has the overall
communication structure as shown here
first the robots read this structure
light pattern from a projector above to
localize and then sends that information
to a central computer which then we saw
sends back the desire states for each
robot and so in the first chapter I will
first talk about how to display
information visually through motion and
so what's basically the main research
question is how do we design expressive
multi robot motion first if we start
with a simple single robot we have three
degrees of freedom and so we can
leverage this we can leverage philosophy
or and acceleration or even its path to
convey information and so researchers
have leveraged these features to convey
successfully convey information like
content and ethic but what happens if
you have many robots you have n times
thought these reviews of freedom and so
how can you best leverage these
additional degrees of freedom from pests
literature we observed mainly two ways
either through the use of icons or
through abstract motion for iconic
display researchers like Alonso Mora
have looked at how to coordinate these
robots spatially and temporally to
deliver graphical representations of the
content similar to how screens use
pixels and while this is on Val
this is a valid method in some cases it
doesn't work like when the robots are
already doing other tasks like
navigation or manipulation on the other
end
abstract motion can be leveraged even
while completing other tasks the
challenge with abstract motion is that
we don't know how to best leverage take
advantage of and parameterize these
additional robots you could have the
robots move independently with different
speeds and paths but with so many robots
it's difficult to scale and understand
what these motions into a V mean to
address this scaling issue we were
inspired by swarms in nature these
organisms like flocks of birds and
schools of fish are able to exhibit
complex behaviors through a simple
distributive rules and so while these
animals use these behaviors as means for
survival I see an opportunity to use
these behaviors to generate more
expressive swarm robot motion and so I
first identified five different types of
behaviors from prior literature
including the ones shown here and in
addition to behavior prior works and
single robot motion perception have
shown that speed and Spooner's have
significant effects and so I expected
that these could also be used to
generate multi expressive multi robot
motion and so to address the main
emphasis question I first hypothesize
that swarm behaviors will have
significant effect on human perception
and thus can be leveraged to generate
expressive swarm about motion prior work
on prior work has shown that number of
robots even this number of robots affect
human perception I also expect that as I
said before the speed and smoothness
will have significant significant
effects similar to the prior work so to
study this we performed a crowdsource
between-subjects experiment the
crowdsource study allowed us to reach
large population more quickly and
allowed us to use a between subjects
study design and that allowed
participants to only watch one motion
instead of all of the motions and that
uses user fatigue as well as carryover
context and sensitization effects
so before doing a video study we looked
at prior literature that compares
results from live and video based
studies so woods at all have studied how
people perceive robots when they
approach them from different angles and
found comparable results from both live
and video based studies and so because
our study is also purely visual similar
to their study we concluded that video
based trial will be sufficient so to run
the online study I film all the motions
and here are the videos of different
form behaviors with the robots including
rendezvous dispersion random tourists
and flock
I also varied the speed to see its
effect
I also changed smoothness so it's either
smooth or synchronously jittery or
asynchronously jittery and so overall we
had three dependent variables that
includes Form behaviors speed and
smoothness so after watching the video
of different motion participant were
asked to rate their perception of the
robots we first measure urgency as we
envision that robots will be around us
and we'll have to convey information
with varying urgency we also looked at
more robot specific perception like
anima see likeability and perceived
safety and these measures allow us to
design behaviors that are likeable safe
and has varying amount of enemy see user
experience is also important for
designing any interaction and so I use
this questionnaire to measure hedonic
pragmatic and attractive qualities and
lastly I measure participants in
perceiving motion because it can be an
implicit indication of the state of the
robots it can be used to indicate how
busy the robots are or how well they're
solving a task so after running the
align study with 962 participants we
analyze the results and highlight some
of us to display significant results
here in each box the mean value and
standard errors are shown and the
results show that as I hypothesized
swarm behavior does significant effect
user perception in many categories
including some of which are shown here
so both rendezvous and dispersion were
perceived quite similarly but they were
perceived differently from others form
behaviors such as random tours and flock
and that suggests that except for render
of wind dispersion others are perceived
differently and can be used to convey
different types of information for speed
and smoothness they yielded similar
results as prior work on single robot
motion perception so faster speed was
perceived as more rousing hedonic anima
and urgent
whereas for smoothness smoother motion
was perceive as more hedonic and
likeable and these against results again
support our hypothesis and so overall
all of these results can be used as
guidelines for future robot designers
when they're developing abstract swarm
Roshan so is then as an example we
demonstrate one of our own examples so
imagine your phone is on a desk and
someone is calling you about urgent
matter how should we design the swarm
motion so first we would consider what
perception we want to elicit since it's
an urgent call we want that you alert
the user in a pleasant manner so we look
at the relevant categories such as these
and first for behavior we can see that
random and dispersion have this desired
high arousal and urgency however as we
want to draw users attention toward a
specific point within in this case which
is the phone we chose the rendezvous
behavior if it was a non urgent call we
could have used flocking behavior as as
it has lower induced arousal for speed
we chose faster speed due to its higher
rating and arousal and urgency and
lastly for smoothness we chose a
smoother motion as it is rated more
likeable than jittery motions they're
also interaction effects between speed
and smoothness force for arousal and
willingness to attend
however for both fast and smooth motion
was still the most arousing and had the
highest rating for willingness to tense
sort so it works
so here's the resulting fast smooth
friend of emotion and so to summarize in
this first chapter we looked at how to
embed expressiveness into swarmer about
motion and as we hypothesize swarm
behavior speed and smoothness all had
significant effects and thus could be
leveraged to generate more expressive
swarm robot motion similar to a previous
chapter here we also explored how to
visually display information in this
case the intent of the robots so as we
see increasing number of robots it is
important for the robots to accomplish
tasks in a not only in an efficient
manner but also in a legible matter to
allow users to read and predict where
the robots is going to do if preferably
even before the execution and so the
main research question for this chapter
is how can you enable users to read and
understand the intent of the both of
multi robot systems and so for a single
robot dragon at all have introduced this
concept of legible motion and how its
different fundamentally from a
predictable motion for a predictable
motion the main objective is get to the
target as efficiently as possible and so
this usually leads to a straight path
unless there's a obstacle in between on
the other hand legible motion the main
objective is enable a observer to be
able to understand where the robot is
going to preferably early on and so this
led to a curved path where initially
moves away from the on target to
indicate that that's not the target
and so you could apply the same concept
to a multi robot system where the robots
follow this curved path however there
are costs associated with path based
legible motion because for users who
already know where the target is there's
a mismatch between the expected and
legible path in the beginning and thus
that can create confusion
there's also increase in trajectory
length and with more robots that becomes
even more significant
fortunately swarms of robot have other
features other motion features that
could be leveraged robots could uses
their shape conforming to an error like
shape to point
where the target is while following a
straight path they can also change the
distribution or density within this
overall shape to guide users attention
toward the goal or they could leverage
one of the Swan behaviors when the Roo
behavior to all merge toward this target
so out of these features I was
particularly interested in density and
renderview behavior density is
interesting because it is one of the few
attentive processing features along with
color and size and these features can be
detected very rapidly by human eyes and
thus could be used to generate legible
motion that can be quickly understood on
the other hands form behavior especially
rendezvous behavior could be used to
improve legibility by having many robots
from different directions all merged
toward our goal so the research question
for this chapter is how do we leverage
these features to generate legible
motion and how do they perform in
comparison
so we first formulate the problem as
follows we have the robots on one side
shown by the blue circles as well as row
of possible targets on the other and
there are many parameters that determine
how difficult the task is such as the
premise shown here and I determined the
values experimentally through pilot
studies to create a sufficiently
challenging task however for one of the
parameters I decide to vary its value as
I expect it to have different effects
based on the type of legible motion in
order to create a baseline for
comparison we generated the control
condition where the robots move
synchronously to straight toward the
goal an optimization that minimizes the
trajectory length is used to compute
this trajectory and that results in a
motion something like this to generate
path based legible motion we use the
same objectives from latest prior work
on single robot legible motion I won't
have time to go into all the detail but
the resulting motion is looks something
like this where it initially moves more
quickly towards the target and then
plateaus
and but still maintains the formation to
generate density based legible motion I
use findings from vision perception
research especially use the features
that are considered pre-attentive
such as color so there are features that
are considered pre-attentive such as
color density in size and here I use
density because it doesn't require any
external light sources or shape changing
capabilities and so my approach has been
to create this denser region within the
overall shape and have that pointed
towards the target and so to implement
this I use an algorithm called centroid
the Voronoi tessellation which has been
used to fill a shape evenly evenly and
so are you so this has been used to
generate evenly filled shapes with
robots for animation purpose so I use
the same algorithm to fill these two
regions with specified number of robots
to generate this desired configuration
so after computing this desired
configurations each robot needs to be
assigned to one of the positions in that
configuration and so I used the
Hungarian algorithm to us to compute the
optimal assignment and finally I also
adjusted the speed of each of the robots
to ensure based on the distance and to
ensure that they'll reach this desired
configuration early on early on while
still moving towards the goal and so the
resulting motion is shown here so the
robots quickly moved towards this
desired configuration and then maintains
it until the end lastly I want to
leverage form behavior especially the
rendezvous behavior to enhance
legibility for wonderful behavior the
agent typically moved towards the same
point but as these are real robots that
can't be where there can't be any
overlap I use I computed the
configuration where the robots are
packed as closely as possible using
prior literature on circle packing then
I use the same Hungary Hungarian
algorithm to find the optimal
assignments and then generate a straight
path towards that assignment for each
robot
and so the resulting motion is as shown
here where the robots the center of the
robot maintained the straight path but
then the robots all merge towards this
target so now that we have defined and
designed these different types of
logical motion we want to compare their
performance so for the study I had the
following independent variables so first
there were different legibility cues
including the control condition we also
vary the initial radius as we expect it
to have different effects on legibility
cues and then finally we also looked at
target difficulty and that's determined
by how many targets are next to the goal
and so the three innermost targets or
label as hard as they have two other
targets next to them whereas the two
outer ones or label at label that's easy
as they only have one other targets and
we looked at this because for path based
legible motion we expect this to have an
effect as the path based legible motion
has an algorithm that depends on the
relative locations of the target and so
first I made hypotheses on the effects
of legibility cues specifically I
expected all legible motion to improve
the eligibility for path based one has
been shown true for a single robot
motion and for the other two conditions
they have some sort of additional cue
about where the target is and so I
expected to improve legibly they are
compared to the control condition I also
looked at made hypotheses on target
difficulty as I said before because path
basis logical motion has algorithm that
depends on the relative location of the
targets I expected to suffer based on
the target difficulty whereas the other
ones it only depends on the absolute
position of the target and so it will it
won't be affected by target difficulty
so for the study we used a between
subjects online study where 231
participants viewed a video online so
the task for the participants was to
watch this video moving towards a target
and then their job was to stop the video
when they were confident where the goal
was they
then selected the target they thought
the robots are going to by selecting one
of that grace or gray circles for each
trial I measure the production
production time production conference as
well as accuracy and using these
measures I computed a overall legibly
score using a formula from prior work I
also asked them to rate the
predictability and legibility of the
motion so I asked them to predict as
soon as they think they have an answer
and so people will obviously have
different standards for that but we
looked across different people so yeah
so looking at the results for legibility
cues we saw that for both prediction
confidence as well as self-reported
legibility rating only rendezvous
behavior performed sniffly better than
the control condition thus supporting
only our third hypothesis and not the
others and this is surprising especially
for path based legible motion as it has
been shown to improve legibility for a
single robot this suggests that perhaps
even just increasing the number of
robots improve legibility what further
investigation will be needed to confirm
this for effects of target difficulty we
saw significant effects on prediction
confidence prediction accuracy and
overall legibility score as expected we
saw significant difference between the
target difficulties for path based
legible motion and we all but we do not
see any significant effect of target
difficulty for density or render vu
based legible motion and that supports
all of our three hypotheses one
additional interesting trend was that
path base legible motion had the highest
overall legibly score when the target
was easy and so this suggests that
perhaps an ideal legible motion would be
composed of would use path based legible
motion when the target is easy but then
use rendezvous base
motion for harder targets and so the
goal of chapter 2 was to visually convey
intent of the robots using the motion
and the results show that rendezvous
behavior performed the best
however there other trends that suggest
that perhaps a best solution would be
composed of a mixture of these different
legibility cues based on the context of
the task and so the two previous
chapters were focused on leveraging
motion to visually display information
this chapter will look at how to
leverage motion to use touch from a
swarm of robots so touch is an integral
part of our daily lives it allows us to
not only the screen shapes and textures
but also is embedded in our social
interactions and effective communication
and so to integrate touch and human
robot interaction researchers have
studied haptic interaction with a single
humanoid or two morphing robot for
instance has been shown that humans
touching a robot can have positive
effects such as improving the mood and
social stimulating social interaction
among elderly fewer works have explored
robots touching humans has been shown to
have positive impact on the amount of
effort people put on task and perceive
unfairness and so while people have
looked at haptic interaction with a
single humanoid or zoomorphic robot not
have looked at haptic interaction with a
swarm of non humanoid robots and as I
introduced in the introduction we
envision that swarms of robots will be
ubiquitous and accomplishing meaningful
tasks like sensing and manipulation and
then when it's necessary they will
approach us to provide direct haptic
notifications that can be tailored to
convey different messages we also see a
good opportunity use these robots as a
medium for among social touch enabling
people in distant places to connect
through touch
so for this work we focus on the touch
or haptic display with form robots so
first to better understand what can what
can be done with this type of system we
first began by exploring its design
space we then studied how human perceive
different touched in life from the
robots and we delve deeper into the
remote social touch application and ran
a study to derive this user define
interactions for social touch so we
first look at the design space of haptic
stimuli with the robots and so with a
single robot you could provide forces of
different types either normal or shear
by translating and rotating the robot we
can vary the frequency at which we apply
these forces either high or low as well
as the amplitudes of the forces and as
the robot is mobile you can also change
where the robot provides the haptic
feedback it can be your finger your palm
or your forearm and it can also be any
other any other part that is on a flat
surface but research has shown that arm
is the most social socially acceptable
body part to touch and so in this work
we primarily focus on how to display on
users forearm but they swarm robots one
of the simplest thing you can change its
number of robots it can be one too few
too many robots you can also change how
they are spatially distributed it can be
on one side or both side of the arm to
provide a squeezed sensation you can
also change the temporal coordination
among the robots it can be synchronous
or sequential to provide this
stroke-like sensation we can also
coordinate the forces of the robots it
can be homogeneous or heterogeneous yes
for this one the hyuna's passive is just
receiving yeah so another interesting
design space is their visible motion so
as the robots have to produce haptic
sensations have to move to produce
haptic sensations there's inherently
this visible motion their companies to
haptic sting line and so for instance
when the robots are providing this
wave-like haptic stim line you also see
this motion wave-like motion and so this
visual aspect is unique to our system as
other haptic devices are as
you say warn or he'll buy the user and
so you can't see it at all so with this
type of haptic stimuli
one question we had was how do people
perceive touch from swarm robots to get
a better sense we ran a perception study
where participants receive different
haptic stimuli and then self-reported
their perception and so out of the
parameters that we discussed earlier we
first chose to look at a subset of the
due to time constraint in particular we
decide to study the lower-level
parameters like force parameters as well
as number of robots is there no other
work that look at our effective have to
display with swarm robots we formed our
hypothesis based on prior work and swarm
robot motion perception and haptics and
so similar to prior work gains form
about motion perception we expect
increasing that number increasing number
of robots will increase arousal urgency
and valence and similar to work in
haptics we expect higher force amplitude
to be less pleasant and higher frequency
forces to be more arousing and urgent
and so to measure human perception of
the robots we use similar metrics as in
Chapter one and so I won't go into
detail here so we had to set up as above
or robots provide haptic patterns to the
users forearm so yeah so for the trial
the robots will align themselves move
forward making contact with the users
forearm and then provide three
repetitions of the haptic stimuli and
then move back the users will then fill
out a set of questionnaire on an iPad so
for the results for number of robots we
found the following results as we
hypothesized increasing the number of
robots increased arousal and urgency but
not the valence it actually decreased
the perceived variance and this is just
that while seeing more robots is
pleasant having more robots touch you is
less pleasant so similar to prior works
in haptics we saw that higher force
amplitudes were less pleasant and that
higher frequency forces were more
arousing and urgent so the main takeaway
is that there's a trade-off when you
increase the number of robots for touch
interactions
and that increases their urgency and
arousal but comes at the cost of
likability and perceived safety so
lastly we dove deeper into the remote
social touch application and the first
question we had is how should the robots
convey social touch with swarming robots
you have many degrees of freedom so it's
unclear how to best coordinate these
robots to best capture this we ask the
users themselves to generate appropriate
behaviors for different social touch
so we first generated this set of
reference for our list station by
looking at prior work and Jones that
I'll have identified different
categories for meanings of touch as
shown here and we also want to convey
basic set of emotions so we took
Eggman's six emotions so given the
reference shown before we ask the
participants to use the above setup to
generate the appropriate inaction that
best conveys the message they use a
multi-touch screen to control up to four
robots which they could test on
themselves before deciding on the most
representative interaction and so from
previous study we found that force
amplitude plays a significant role and
so for this study we used a bigger robot
that's capable of outputting larger
amount of forces okay so here are some
of the example interactions that the
participant came up with given the
reference shown on the left left
participants brainstorm and then as the
different interactions before selecting
the most representative ones some of
which are shown here so one of the
interesting trend was that people use
visual effects of the motion as well as
the contact location to deliver this
contextual information that's hard to
convey especially for abstract social
touch and so or to convey surprise
emotion participant uses this first
motion to where the robots move away
from the forearm to convey afraid
emotion participants had a robot hide in
the corner of the users arm and so the
main takeaways for this study is that
the visual aspect as well as the contact
location is important especially to
provide this contextual information
that's hard to convey
touch alone and so that in Chapter three
I looked at how to leverage touch from
the robots and the two studies I ran
showed that it's important to consider
the number of robots that touch users as
well as how and where the robots move to
provide these haptic stimuli so in the
last three chapters I talked about how
the robots should convey information to
the users in the last one I will switch
gears and talk about how to enable users
to command large number of robots for a
single robot researchers have developed
many different ways to control it and
that include verbal nonverbal and
written through coding which is
primarily used by experts however with a
large number of robots it becomes a much
more challenging task especially for non
expert users who are not used to
interacting with robots there have been
some attempts to address this
researchers have tried using EMG and IMU
sensors to detect muscle signals of the
users forearm to derive this set of hand
gestures for controlling multi robot
systems people also have used computer
vision to the deck gesture and body
posture and derive this set of control
gestures and while these are while these
provide a mean means to control multi
robot systems they don't take into
account users preference and rather it
only focuses on what the sensors can
detect and differentiate and so instead
of the previous bottom-up approach where
the sensors are chosen first and then
they choose a set of gestures that this
sensor can distinguish I flip this
around and use a top-down approach by
first focusing on how the users prefer
to control command command large number
of robots and so prior works in HCI and
HR I have taken similar approach to
generate user-defined gestures for
different applications like surface
surface computing and human drone
interaction in our case the main
research question is how the users
prefer to command a large number of
robots how
is it different from the expert define
or sensor-based
command set and what modality to people
use to four different commands we also
looked at an effect of number of robots
as prior work has shown that people's
perception change based on the number of
robots and work in psychology have shown
that individual behavior changes based
on the presence of others and lastly we
also wanted to look at the effect of
proximity to the robots prior work on HR
I have shown that human perception
changes based on proximity and so to
test this question we had several
independent variables including number
of robots where vary from 1 5 to 20 we
also tested two different proximity
zones either intimate or personal and we
also compile this list of different
control different commands for multi
robot systems from prior work and it can
be categorized - robot selection in a
robot interaction user robot interaction
and robot environment interaction to run
the study we had the following setup
with a TV monitors showing the pictorial
prompt and the robots were placed on a
tab table with users standing next to it
and so the procedure were as was as
followed first we show the participants
this pictorial flash car contained the
initial and final state of the robots we
then ask them to perform whatever action
they think is necessary to command the
robots to go from the initial to the
final state we told them there are no
constraints and we told them that there
were no constraints after each trial we
asked the participants to recall and
explain their actions to get a better
understanding of what they did and why
they did it so first looking at the
first research question we compiled a
user-defined interaction set by
combining responses from the users some
of the examples are shown here so to
move - to command a robot to move to a
specific location people point it and
for a larger number of robots they just
grabbed one instead of controlling all
of them
and so combining all of the users
command we generate this user-defined
command set I won't have time to go into
all details about all of this but you
can check with me later so here's the
breakdown of the modality for all of the
user generate interaction and so we
found that gesture is the most common
modality and that supports the prior
work that mostly leverages gesture for
multi robot systems however they're all
there's still significant numbers of
touch and verbal interactions and so the
control set is multimodal but with an
emphasis on gesture we also see oh and
saw an interesting trend were verbal
commands were almost always accompanied
by gesture so even for participants who
his primary modality was verbal you can
see that this gesture on the side of the
his body and when I asked him afterwards
he said he didn't notice that he was
using it but you just have to
consciously used it to compliment the
verbal command the second question was
about effective number of robots and we
did indeed see this effect and so even
for similar tasks people use varying
number of hands or fingers based on the
number of robots and so we saw this
effect for both gesture and touch
interaction for a gesture we saw that
with the increase of number of robots we
saw increase in two-handed gestures and
decrease and one or two use of one or
two fingers and similar trend was also
observed in touch interaction and one
participant there other participant as
well but one participant noted that I
often wanted to use both hands when
interacting with a group of robots even
though I already knew that a single hand
would work the same and so because there
was no constraint they could use
whatever number of robots but they still
compelled to use more hands we also saw
an effect on how people control many
robots through touch with more robots
instead of trying to directly touch all
of the robot
it's like here participants were more
likely to use a different approach where
they only control a subset of the robots
and expected the others to follow or
some only used one of the robots and
expected the rest to follow as well so
if we're touching this interaction we
saw this shift in control paradigm as
number of robots is increased instead of
trying to control all of the robots
people only touch subset of the robots
and expected the others to follow and
last question was about effective
proximity we also observe significant
effects for proximity especially we saw
that approximately affected how many
hands people use when the robots were
further away people tend to use more
one-handed gesture while we don't we
didn't investigate the exact reason
behind this we suspect that it had to do
with the fact that people tended to lean
in when the robots were further away and
so it's more difficult to use two-handed
gestures when they were leaning and so
they relied on one-handed gesture more
and so to summarize the goal of this
chapter was to investigate how to enable
users to command large number of robots
we ran a study and found that people use
multi modal inputs with emphasis on
gesture and that number of robots as
well as proximity affects how people
control command and so that implies that
an ideal system interface will require
this robot state-dependent vocabulary to
accommodate users and so in summary the
goal of this thesis was to answer the
following question how do we interact
with multi robot systems I broke it down
into two components display via motion
and command and looked at how to
generate multi modal output from the
robots using the motion of the robots
and how to understand multi modal input
from the users here I summarized the
findings from each chapter
for first first chapter we found that so
on behavior speed and smoothness they
all can be leveraged to generate more
expressive motion and for to create to
convey intent swarm behavior has been
found to be the most effective but
perhaps an ideal one we'll use a mixture
of different legibility cues for how to
display with robots we saw that number
of robots is very important and also the
visual aspect of the motion as well as
contact location is important and lastly
for the command large number of robots
people use multimodal input and number
of robots as well as proximity affects
how people command large number of
robots and so well I investigated
several aspects of human multi robot
interaction there's still many more
pieces that could be explored in the
future one of which is context most of
the studies I've read didn't have
specific context or a setting and so and
that was done on purpose
to generate more generalizable results
however when designing interaction with
real robots at real application it will
be necessary to confirm whether these
results hold or if different in action
is needed another aspect that could be
useful to explore in the future is size
this current thesis uses small robots
soit's that are inherently safe it has
many benefits but if we change the size
any drastically we can expect the
international experience will also
drastically change for instance when you
have large larger robots the perceived
safety will be a much more important
criteria for an interaction and as we
see - as we see emergence of robots like
autonomous vehicles and delivery robots
this aspect of size is important to
explore and so mark Weiser once famously
said the most profound technologies are
those that disappear and swarms of
centimeter scale robots have this
ability to literally disappear into the
background but then also come out
into our foreground when it's needed and
so I plan on continue to study this
ubiquitous interaction with multi about
systems and also how to leverage these
robots as programmable physical tools
that can help people achieve their goals
in a way that has been possible before
and so in conclusion the robots will
become robots will become ubiquitous on
our streets and home robots will be
physically moving around sensing our
environment manipulating objects but
then also interact with us visually and
through touch and so in this with this
thesis I hope to have made some progress
towards enabling this feature of your
biggest robots we're almost at the end
and I just want to take short amount of
time to thank everyone who's been
involved in this one way or the other I
want to thank my advisor Sean Fullmer
for being an inspiration figure
throughout this journey and making this
possible due to time I'll be short with
this I know you took a little longer and
I thank all the committee members for
being here for introduced me to the
field of haptics HCI HRI and making this
whole thesis possible I also want to
thank all my collaborators for making
this all of these works possible it
would it would have been impossible
without everyone's help especially my
Tivo jock for building the robots
together with me I want to thank past
and current Shakey's they were
instrumental in running and designing
and doing research we also have very
unique lab traditions like TTL which
stands for traditional Tuesday launch
where everyone used to cook not anymore
but you have a different thing going on
I also want to thank my fiance Chen plus
boba which is the famous dog in
Instagram as well as mom dad and my
brother Fred I also want to thank my
friends and different support support
groups including especially Friday night
tennis group it's been great and also
want to thank my funding sources sense
of scholarship and also blender
Institute so thank you all for coming
listening and I'll take any questions
[Applause]
like a lot of work it seems like the
design of the shape of the robots to
your studies
my very easing which was a cylinder
instead of all compared to a cube I
think it was more straightforward in
terms of design and trying to make the
robot as small as possible to use a
cylinder pro cylinder shape comparing
with a cube their literature on
perception of different shapes and
people usually tend to perceive rounder
shapes more positively and so instead of
cube we actually had a cube shaped robot
but didn't end up using it both because
the perception as well as when you touch
it
cubes have you know these pointing more
edges that is not so conducive to touch
so we use this cylinder round shape
connection when using just touch or
whatever because it looks like the table
was so big they want to yeah that's a
great question
so I didn't see any significant
interaction with the data but what I
observed was that and that's because
people who use touch mostly kind of
stuck with touch so it didn't matter
whether the robots were far or close and
I think there was a one video showing
one of the participants like reaching
out and using their hand to do it and so
well a lot of the people like stuck with
the modality that they use initially and
so surprising I didn't see that effect
approximately I think if the robots were
even further away then they would
probably give up trying to use touch but
then for our case I guess it was still
reachable if you lean in and so we
didn't see that effect here how much did
it cost to construct each yeah so right
now we made about like 200 of their
robots so that came out to a cost of
around 50 dollars per robot but I think
if you do mass manufacturing you could
probably make that even lower but for
now we spend around 50 bucks this is a
way to explore the non minimum phase
behavior of some samel devices like like
a standing robot sir or or even drones
were you basically in order to move
forward you have to back back up a
little bit too because that's I just
came from a conference where we had
these standing robots and you know you
don't know whether they move or they
stand are they just displays but if they
move a little bit maybe first away from
me and then then I feel safe and then it
can interact with me I think yeah that's
a very that's a great question I think
so unfortunately those studies Iran
didn't really explore that aspect it's
mostly one direction off for now I am
planning on looking more into this
bidirectional interaction because I
think that's definitely more important
in the future where you know you're not
only gonna be receiving or or sending
and so I think this yeah as you said
this interaction is much more important
I think to to implement that non-minimum
phase directional movement yeah but it's
harder to design it because you have
this bi-directional aspect of it so yeah
okay thank you all for coming was a
pleasure and happy Friday
[Applause]